wir wollen einmal ganz kurz schauen in
eine bäckerei zu einem bäcker nach
hannover gerhard bosselmann der ein
dramatisches video auf facebook gepostet
hat und der uns einen einblick gibt in
die sorgen die viele menschen die
fleißig zur arbeit gehen und sich gerade
gedanken um ihre zukunft machen
gerade haben das ist eine katastrophe
wir müssen uns selbst helfen und sie als
unsere kunden können uns helfen und in
schlechten zeit zu uns halten wie wir
das auch tun
ich möchte mich bei meiner belegschaft
bedanken die wundervollen bitte gehen
sie zu ihrem bäcker ob ergraute wrabetz
geheißen es ist völlig egal
gehen sie zu ihrem bäcker um die ecke
die bäcker aus hannover sind für sie da
und scheiß egal wie der heißt gehen sie
einfach hin weil sie retten damit
arbeitsplätze der bosselmann sind 205
und wir haben alle unsere jobs einen
scheiß angst ab heute gilt bei den
bosselmann filialen folgen dass wir
werden etwa zehn jahren schließen müssen
wir wissen nicht wie es weitergeht
informieren sie sich auf facebook und
instagram über die öffnungszeiten
aber ich habe noch etwas mehr am herzen
nicht mein sohn ist arzt in tübingen und
ich möchte ab heute dass alle
mitarbeiter im gesundheitsdienst alle
ärzte krankenschwestern
rettungswagenfahrer kriegen ab sofort
alles was sie brauchen
an haushaltsüblichen bhagwan der
bosselmann umsonst in guten zeiten haben
wir zusammen gehalten in schlechten
zeiten tun wir es noch mehr bitte
missbrauchen sie das nicht aber alle
rettungskräfte sind jederzeit herzlich
willkommen als dankeschön
ich hoffe dass wir uns einen acht wochen
fröhlich wieder sehen wir unser neues
konzept oberrieder aufmachen und mit so
viel herzblut für sie in acht wochen
wieder da sein können oder in 12 oder
whenever wenn ich möchte mit ansatz
schließen
der in unserer neuen restaurant bobo an
der wand hängt in the world bekannt
das treibt einem die tränen in die augen
wenn man das sieht und das ist nur ein
kleinunternehmer in deutschland dem es
so geht die unzähligen gerade was ist
ihre botschaft an diese menschen
zunächst einmal in dem fall sogar noch
eine relativ gute situation weil es im
lebensmittel geht und lebensbild bleiben
ja offen erlebt hat zum teil dieser tage
wie welche art von käufen auch stadt
wien amtstag läufen über andere produkte
über die ich noch nie gehört habe das
ist ein mangel geben soll wenn wir
bayern noch einmal ganz bewusst auch die
lebensmittelversorgung angesprochen und
die lebensmittelhändler und auch fest
zwischen festzustellen und
sicherzustellen dass da alles
funktioniert übrigens auch die
europäische union dringend gefragt die
wahren und lieferverkehr in ganz europa
herzustellen jetzt übrigens die
bewertung stunde auch für die
europäische union
nicht nur dass ich wie jetzt hier aus
china solche lieferungen kommen sondern
in europa dafür zu sorgen dass nur der
eine teil der andere heißt schnelle
soforthilfe in bayern gibt es dass wir
zahlen bereits aus bis zu 30.000 euro
sofort geld das bedeutet ist kein
darlehen ist keine bürgschaft das ist
direkt geld sozusagen aufs konto oder
auch die hand der mit der unternehmen
der nächsten ein zwei wochen liquidität
halten können
wir haben das als erstes bundesland
gemacht ich würde das andere folgen
wollen dringend notwendig so etwas zu
tun
denn da besteht letztlich die
entscheidende herausforderung betriebe
zu erhalten
daneben dann wenn man mal diese
überbrückung hat mit dieser
liquiditätshilfe dann können auch
entsprechende bürgschaften eintreten
wichtig dabei dass die hausbanken
mitmachen
deswegen auch da ein appell wir machen
beier nächsten bank im gespräch dass
neben einer großzügigen
bürgschaftsrahmen die bund und land also
in jedem fall der freistaat bayern geben
bis zu 90 prozent ausfall garantie für
kredite dass die banken aber schon
mitmachen und jetzt nicht kredite
verhindern sondern diese kredite
freiwillig und großzügig auch geben
letzter satz dazu
dazu muss auch die banken regulation
etwas gelockert werden
denn die strengen regeln die wir hatten
die helfen jetzt leider nicht sondern
die bewirken sogar eine bremse bei der
vergabe von schnellen unbürokratischen
krediten